welcome to GameSpot gameplay where we
show you some clips at 2:00 and 7:00
p.m. Pacific every day so you can make
your own decisions about games during
the lulls between big titles I keep
finding myself going back to Star Wars
Battlefront 2 we played the hell out of
that bill that III and one of the things
that struck me was how the air game has
changed I've come to accept we're
probably not going to get the capital
ship to capital ship combined-arms
battles that made previous battlefront
games so special but that doesn't mean
the air game can't be an important part
of the map one of the larger
improvements in particular is that the
air-to-ground game feels a lot more
relevant in Battlefront 2 than it did in
the previous battlefront where it could
often feel very disconnected from
objectives one of the larger
improvements in particular is how a good
air-to-ground game can earn you enough
points to buy a hero and get that win we
were able to chain the vulture droid
into buying Darth Maul who he actually
played in a similar support role
skirting the edge of the map and
removing roadblocks for our team as an
old x-wing in battlefront player the air
game does feel a bit diminish from
earlier versions of battlefront but
heading back in the right direction
how do you feel about the air game in
Battlefront to you so far we're gonna
find out more about it at Gamescom
coming up in mid-august including
getting a closer look at space battles
so give us the old thumbs up and
subscribe to our channel so we can get
that to you alright let's get to it
the transport has reached wing point -
with minimal damage efficiency
[Music]
all units protect the transport
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
transport prepared to fire at the palace
[Music]
[Music]
the MTT has arrived in position despite
severe damage terminate my sword program
and begin that cycle phase two begins
and shortly proceed to the palace and
trends have been captured designated
positions the clothes have delayed you
too long
okay my grasp
watch their eyes
secured opposition remains is stronger
than predicted by squads and prepare for
phase three
proceed inside the palace for a final
conquest seize designated areas before
enemy reinforcements arrive
scream
I promise a quick end
[Music]
[Music]
Roger Roger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the carrying the throne-room
win or be deactivated
[Music]
superior weapons and bull gravity have
triumphed the palace has fallen